in this video Brandon will teach you
about 10 Common JavaScript security
vulnerabilities and how to protect
against them Brandon is an engineer at
semrep and teaches at Carnegie Mellon
University to make it interesting and
fun it's in a quiz format he shows you a
small code snippet and asks you to find
the vulnerabilities feel free to pause
the video to see if you can answer after
that he talks about the vulnerabilities
explains how they are vulnerable and
provides an example of remediation code
some grep provided a grant to make this
video possible Sam grep is an open
source code security tool that can find
vulnerabilities in your code and your
dependencies how much do you know about
software security think you've got what
it takes to diagnose a real vulnerable
application my name is Brandon I'm a
program analysis engineer at a software
security company called semdrep in this
video I'll be showing you 10 examples of
common vulnerabilities in real code and
I'm here to challenge you on how many of
them you can figure out your goal will
be to figure out both the kind of
vulnerability demonstrated as well as
how it can be exploited I'll show you
the code and then go over the answers
with you afterwards give it a try you
might just learn something
all right without further Ado let's get
started this first example I have for
you is in JavaScript and it's just
rendering a simple web app this is known
to be vulnerable I'll talk a little bit
about what it does and then I'll let you
try to figure out why it's vulnerable so
this query params demo it was demoing
query parameters uh what's happening is
that we're using this use Query function
we defined and using this use location
function that we imported from this
react router Dom library and what that's
doing is it's constructing this new
object of the URL search params class
now the point of this class is that it
lets us interface with these things
called query parameters uh for instance
if our website that this web app was at
was https colon example.com and let's
say slash settings or a query parameter
is something that looks like this it's
redirect equals Foo what this means is
that redirect is being is a query
parameter whose value is Foo and that
means that when we click on this button
over here we're going to get that query
parameters value so we'll get the foo
here and then clicking upon this return
home button will end up making us go to
that whatever that value is okay so for
instance if this was our overall URL of
the website that we were at
so that means that clicking on this
return home button would make us go to
this URL in other words going home
uh so I'll let you think a little bit
about why this is vulnerable but we'll
come back in a second and talk about it
all right let's get into it so this code
is vulnerable because of a vulnerability
called cross-site scripting cross-site
scripting is when a malicious attacker
tries to get code to execute on your
machine through your browser they try to
get a script to run across site so in
this particular example this has to do
with this query parameters thing I was
talking about earlier in particular uh
something you need to know about is this
JavaScript protocol the JavaScript
protocol means that when you visit a URL
that looks like JavaScript colon slash
everything after the slash slash is
interpreted as JavaScript code and
executed within your browser that means
that if I were to write do something bad
as a function call here if I visited
this URL it would try to execute this do
something bad function which potentially
could be unsafe because it could execute
arbitrary code now in particular if we
combine it with this query parameter
idea we know that for this code for this
website and if I click the return home
button it'll take this value from the
redirect query parameter and go to it in
particular though we might actually take
this and put it in place of that query
parameters value meaning that if this
were our URL if we clicked on this
button instead of visiting
um you know Foo or home or whatever we
would visit this which executes the do
something bad or any kind of arbitrary
code that means that someone might give
us a malicious link that could execute
arbitrary code in our machine a
cross-site scripting attack
to fix this what we need to do is we
need to sanitize the URL or validate it
to make sure that we're not going to run
into this JavaScript protocol attack so
what we're going to do is we're going to
do that by writing this validate URL
function and we're going to take in this
URL so what we're going to do is first
we're going to create a new URL object
using this built-in URL class and what
this will do is it'll give us access to
some other information about this URL in
particular we want to know what its
protocol is we know that if it's a
JavaScript protocol that's pretty unsafe
but also in particular https is okay so
let's say that we're going to condition
on whether or not this user supplied URL
object whether or not it's protocol is
equal to https and if it is then we know
we're safe in that case we're just going
to return the original URL we were given
because we know that it's not going to
cause an attack otherwise if we're not
then let's just say we return slash
which will essentially make us go home
and then once we have this validate URL
function we're going to pass in the
value that we got from the query
parameter into it so that we can
validate the URL and make sure that we
don't
fall prey to a cross-site scripting
attack
and that's all
okay let's get into the second example
so this is another JavaScript program
and it's just defining a simple web app
that listens for get requests it's going
to be listening on this endpoint slash
API data so if we had our previous
website as before example.com API data
it's listening to these requests and
like the previous example it's using
query parameters in particular we're
looking at this URL query parameter
which will look like this
so in this example if we were to visit
this URL the foo would be what gets
assigned to this URL const and then what
happens is the web app will then fetch
the data from that URL and then return
it turn into a Json and then return it
back to the user now going along with
this uh in this in this hypothetical
example we have some kind of like
internal website uh where we're storing
our data and there's some publicly
facing data like we have this
countries.json uh file that is publicly
facing and there's also a states.json
publicly facing data
um so if we were to visit these two URLs
what would happen is that the web app
would then read in the query parameter
and then try to fetch the data from this
internal states.json or countrys.json
all right try to figure out why it's
vulnerable and then we'll come back and
talk about it in a second
okay let's do it so this code is
vulnerable because of a vulnerability
called server side request forgery or
ssrf for short what that means is that
an attacker tries to dupe a server into
doing dirty work for them by by using
permissions that the attacker wouldn't
ordinarily have by getting the server to
execute some kind of query that the
attacker wouldn't be able to normally do
so in this instance I talked about how
we have this setup that this internal
website has some publicly available data
that we're trying to scrape using this
web app but it's not the case
necessarily that all of the data is
public in fact there might be like some
kind of confidential.json on the server
in which case if we visited this URL we
would then try to we would then get this
URL from the query parameter and This
Server this web app would then fetch the
data from this confidential.json and it
might be able to do it because the
server has more permissions in this case
so we want to make sure that we only
visit the stuff that we're allowed to
this public data without being able to
to to an SSR of attack to get
confidential data we're not supposed to
see so to remind me this something we
can do is we can make a const of allowed
URLs and this is just going to be a list
of two things uh the two let's say
publicly available data jsons that we
want to see so let's put those both of
them in there seats.json
and then what we want to do is we want
to make sure that this URL whatever
we're going to be fetching from is not
not in the loud list so we're going to
say that it's if it's not the case that
allowed URLs includes
this URL
well then we have a problem it's not in
our allowed URLs so what we're going to
do is we're going to do something like
we did down here with these statuses
we're going to return res dot status 400
to Signal there's an error and we're
going to say error
we got a bad URL because we don't want
to visit this URL if it's not allowed
explicitly we don't want the server to
make that mistake and just by doing that
we make sure that we only visit the
public data that we're allowed to
without the server being able to give
away This Confidential data that we
wouldn't want to otherwise and that's
how we prevent an ssrf attack
all right let's talk about the next
example so in this example suppose that
we have some kind of check token
function basically we have some user
supplied information specifying some
kind of account and we want to check
whether or not the user supplied
information has some kind of secret
token that matches the accounts secret
token that's on record and we're going
to use triple equals and return true if
it's true otherwise we'll return false
okay that's it think about why it's
vulnerable and we'll come back and talk
about it in a second
okay this code is vulnerable because of
something called a timing attack
basically what happens is that in
JavaScript When comparing two strings
this triple equals function is going to
just iterate through each character and
compare them and if it's if they don't
match it'll just return false so in
particular suppose that the account
secret token was like ABC well then if
the token that we Supply is like d we
look at a we look at D We compare them
we see that it's false and we return no
but what if it was a little bit more
similar like it was AE well then triple
equals would look at both A's it would
say Okay looks good it would move on to
b and e oh they're not the same it would
return false but if you pay attention
you notice that it takes a little bit
longer before it gets to returning false
in the second case because the prefix
this A and A were actually the same that
means that if a malevolent attacker was
sitting around with their stopwatch
going and they had all the time in the
world they could brute force a bunch of
strings to try and see which which
strings take a little bit longer than
others at which point it would try to it
would figure out that it was getting
closer and closer to the real token that
it wouldn't otherwise know a timing
attack so what we need to do is we try
we want to make sure that that won't
happen we want to make sure that we
don't give away information about the
token based on how fast we return false
so what to fix this what we'll do is
we'll import crypto from this crypto
package and instead of using triple
equals we're going to use a crypto
um equality function that is a little
less transparent about the timing
so this crypto timing safe equal
function is going to be the same as our
triple equals but it'll be better about
not giving away how similar the inputs
were
and just by doing that simple one line
two line change we prevent Us timing
attack
all right example number four so in this
example we've got a validate token
function and it's taking an HTTP request
what's happening is that we're checking
the header the header at this key of
token and we're going to pass it into
this buffer.prom function which decodes
it from this basic C4 encoding
um and then what we're going to do is we
also have the sum object thing which is
let's say empty we want to check whether
or not this token that we pass into the
server is is a member of this sum object
um but right now it's empty so this
should always be boss and then if it
were to be if it were to be in it we
would send true but because it's empty
we should always send false in this case
but I'll tell you that there's a
vulnerability where we can get it to
sometimes send true
all right I'll let you think about it
we'll come back and talk about what the
vulnerability is real soon
all right the vulnerability here has to
do with prototype pollution in
JavaScript the idea is that JavaScript
is a prototype based every object has a
prototype which is a parent class that
it inherits its methods from now the
idea is that if you if you index in with
a string underscore underscore Proto
it'll try and fetch that prototype
object for you and even though the sum
object is empty it does have a prototype
because every object has a prototype so
if you manage to pass in this string
underscore underscore Proto what will
happen is that this sum object indexed
into it is going to fetch that prototype
object it'll end together with the Proto
string and then because those are truthy
this if will actually evaluate to true
and then we'll send true even though it
should have been false even because we
should have been looking for the token
in the object and the token in the
object is empty so it shouldn't have had
the token
so to protect against this we want to
make sure that instead of indexing in
with this token we want to make sure
that we only look at the properties of
the of the object in question and it
turns out we can do that using this has
own property function
so we use this method we pass in the
token and then instead of even if we
were to pass in this underscore
underscore Proto string it's not going
to go and fetch the Proto it's going to
go and just check whether or not that
property exists in the object and
because the object is empty this will
never evaluate to true and then will
never send true and that's how we
prevent the Prototype pollution attack
all right example number five so this is
another JavaScript program that is just
a simple app that's taking in post
requests from slash user what we're
doing is we're looking inside of a
database of users to try and find users
whose username matches the thing that's
in the request if we find it then we
just send it back otherwise we're going
to send an error message
all right think about why this one's
insecure and then come back when you're
done
all right so this code is vulnerable
because of a vulnerability called a
nosql injection which is basically like
the SQL injection but not limited to
just SQL queries in this case the user
could possibly enter a query that could
allow them to access things that they
shouldn't in particular what's happening
is we're finding every entry every
document in our users that has this
username matching
rec.body.username but it's not
guaranteed that rec.body.username needs
to be a string in fact what it might be
is it might be this object here where we
have dollar sign and E
to null and what this means is this is a
special mongodb operator where dollar
sign any means not equal not equal to no
in essence if we were to try and find
with this query instead we would find
every single instance of a user in our
database that had a username where the
unit where the username was set this is
really bad because we're not just
finding the username we're finding
things by the username but finding all
the data Associated to it within our
database that means that this username
could be paired with all sorts of
sensitive data like credit card number
like social security number like date of
birth stuff that we're not supposed to
see so what we want to do is make sure
that someone can't abuse this database
by putting in some malformed query
something that's not a string
essentially
so what we can do is we can do if type
of rec.body.username
and we can case some other that that's
not string and if it's not a string then
it could be one of this mongodb operator
stuff that causes them to create data
that they shouldn't be able to see in
which case what we'll do is we'll return
the status 400 on them and then we'll
say We'll return a message that says
this is a bad username or an invalid
username this way people can't access
stuff that they don't want and we're
only constraining requests that are
actually usernames that they want to
look up this way we prevent the nosql
injection attack
all right challenge six so we've got
another JavaScript program here and
we've got an app taking in post requests
at slash validate email now what we've
got here is assume that this regex is a
gigantically incredibly complex regex
that happens to validate emails and what
we're doing is we're taking in this
ref.body.email in the request and we're
checking for whether or not it passes
against this regular expression if it
doesn't then we'll say invalid email and
complain and otherwise we'll send back
valid as true okay all right try to
figure out why this code is vulnerable
and then we'll talk about it in a second
all right let's talk about it so this
code is insecure because of an attack
called a redos attack or regular
expression denial of service what this
means is that this regular expression is
really complicated don't worry too much
about what it does but it might take a
really long time to validate certain
inputs because the regular expression
has to try out a bunch of options it
might take a very long time depending on
what the input that is being fed into it
is and because the input is under the
control of the person making the request
this is not within our control and you
could potentially be crafted by some
malicious attacker leading to denial of
service because something might hang on
certain inputs so instead of rolling
your own regular expression and doing
this whole thing what we can instead do
is we could say we could use this
validator Library which is very
efficient and then what we'll do instead
is of instead of using this email
regex.test we're going to say if not
valerator.is email which is a function
that already exists
and then this way we can test for
whether or not it adheres to the email
structure both without needing to roll
our own regex and also while ensuring
that we can do so relatively efficiently
and prevent these denial of service
attacks
all right example number seven now this
one's actually not in JavaScript but
it's a Docker file that's running in the
root directory of some node.js
application and what this Docker file is
doing is it's going to create an app
directory it'll copy the package.json
describing the app dependencies to that
directory
um it'll set the user privileges to root
run npm install copy the source of the
app to that directory and then run the
app on Port 8080. okay think about why
this code's vulnerable and then we'll
come back to it in a little bit
okay so this code is vulnerable because
of the potential security
misconfiguration this happens because
when we set the user permissions we set
them to root which means administrator
level privileges on this whole Docker
image this is really bad because
something that happens afterwards like
npm install or even running the server
itself we could be installing some kind
of malicious package or we could have a
vulnerability within the app itself if
this happens that means that because
this whole Docker image has these
administrator level permissions this
could potentially have disastrous
consequences for the machine that we're
running on we don't want to give away
administrator privileges Willy Nelly so
what we can do is instead of doing that
let's run with just user level
permissions so that we don't have the
potential to wreck everything
um if there's something malicious going
on here and by doing this we prevent the
security misconfiguration vulnerability
okay so this code is vulnerable because
of hard-coded credentials we see here
that this conse secret that we have here
my super duper secret key it is pretty
secret but not secret enough because we
have it in our app Source in general
it's not a great idea to hard code
Secrets like this inside of your
application code if you were giving out
the source you'd be able to see it if
you were giving out even a compiled
version it'd be quite possible to
reverse engineer the precise value which
means that your secret would get leaked
which is really really bad so what you
want to do is in general it's a better
practice to use something like
environment variables so we could write
something like
process.n.jwt token which means that
we're reading the environment variable
JWT token to find the identity of the
secret but it's not within the app
Source itself this is both more secure
for the reasons I mentioned earlier as
well as it makes it easier to swap out
the token if we so need to for instance
if we were to compromise our previous
token
so just by using something like
environment variables we no longer have
hard-coded credentials and this is no
longer a security vulnerability
all right example nine we've got another
JavaScript app that's taking in post
requests at a slash sign up endpoint and
what we're doing is we're looking in a
database of users to find a user whose
username matches the username given in
the request and then what we do is if
there's an error we do some error
handling but otherwise if we don't find
that user with that username then we
just insert the rec.body as a new user
and then we return success
try to figure out why this code is
vulnerable and then we'll come back in a
second
all right so this code's vulnerable
because of something called a mass
assignment attack Mass assignment is
when user input might be able to set
properties on an object that it
shouldn't be able to now we the reason
why this so happens is because we're
looking up usernames by the
ref.body.username but if we don't find
it we insert the entire ref.body object
now suppose that our database has a few
things in it Associated to a username
it's not just a username but also let's
say a password an email
engine is admin flag now when we insert
the entire reptile body this could
potentially be an object that sets this
is admin flag that should not be able to
be set by just anybody nobody should be
able to just make themselves an admin
but because we insert the entire reptile
body we don't have control over this and
someone could specify all these fields
together
so what we'll do is instead of inserting
the entire rectal body we'll make a new
object that only sets the things that we
know are safe so we'll set username to
be string of rec.body.username we'll set
email to be string of rep.body.email
and let's also say that we set password
to be string of rec.body.password
it's cool but
but probably not a good idea for us to
store the password in our database in
plain text so what we can do also is we
can do import encrypt password and
supposedly just have this dot slash util
passwords thing lying around and we have
this encrypt password method and the
next thing we'll do is instead of
storing the password as a string we're
just going to call encrypt password on
it
this way we prevent ourselves from the
mass assignment attack but also we
encrypt the password so that it's not
stored in our database in plain text and
just like that we prevent the security
vulnerability
all right violent example so here we've
got this web app that's taking in post
requests and they're taking it a
generate password reset URL link What's
Happening Here is that we're trying to
generate a password reset for some kind
of customer for some web app
um so assume the customer exists we find
the customer using the email and then we
get the password reset token via the
customer's ID what then happens is that
we generate this reset password URL uh
using this rep.header.host using
password reset we just make the URL out
of string interpolation and then we send
back the URL in a Json object
try to figure out why this one's
vulnerable and then we'll talk about it
in a second
okay so this code is vulnerable because
of a host header injection attack the
reason why this might happen is we use
this rec.header of host so we use the
host header basically
um as one of the parameters to this URL
but this is actually under control of
the person making the request in
possible control of the attacker by
convention this is usually just going to
be something that's safe but this could
be changed by the person who's making
the request so in general it's not a
great idea to use the host header
because this could be used to send back
a malicious link that then when clicked
on could send the user anywhere so best
not to to use this host editor so what
we want to do is we want to use
something that's more robust than just
using the host header of the requests
we're getting from the user so suppose
that we have this process.m.host URL
environment variable lying around it
would be a lot safer if in the server in
the web app we were referencing this
host URL instead of looking at the host
header given to us by the request itself
by doing just the simple step we prevent
the host header injection because we're
no longer using a potentially malicious
source of data all right that's it
all right that's the end of the video I
hope you managed to find all 10
vulnerabilities but definitely leave a
comment below on how many of them you
managed to figure out if you want more
resources on how to learn about security
they'll be linked in the description
below but definitely check out some of
the other videos that free codecamp has
they're excellent resources for learning
more about computer science
security is something that's becoming
more and more important by the day so
taking the time to educate yourself now
can pay off a lot in the future
thanks so much for watching the video I
hope you learned something more about
security and until next time